[Musik]
mai zusammen heute gibt es mal was
gesundes ich lese ja eure nachrichten
eure kommentare unter den beiträgen um
die videos und ihr sagt ihr macht doch
mal was gesundes am besten low carb was
vegetarisch ist und ich vereine jetzt
einfach alles und mache jetzt in
leckeren auberginen auflaufen gibt es
bei uns auch immer mal wieder manchmal
als hauptmahlzeit
manchmal wenn ich dann auch gestern habe
einfach auch noch mal so nebenbei weil
dann hat man ja immer gerne verschiedene
sachen auf dem teller und die auswahl
und es geht wirklich super super schnell
und ich fange auch schon direkt an ich
habe hier meine aubergine der mich
einfach nur gewaschen und abgetrocknet
und wird jetzt in dünne scheiben
schneiden
sondern jetzt nehme ich hier mein
backbleche richtig schreiben darauf bei
pinsel sie anschließend mit öl und dann
kommen wir dem backofen
[Musik]
jetzt werden die auberginen schön
gerüstet das ist so ein unterschied
vertraut mir wenn man die wirklich
vorher im ofen rostet und dann erst so
auch noch verarbeitet oder wenn man sie
direkt in die tomatensoße gibt das ist
ein verdammt großer unterschied und
daher lege ich euch das auch ans herz
200 grad ober und unterhitze da brauchen
sie so ungefähr 10 minuten und danach
können wir auch schon weitermachen
[Musik]
wir machen weiter mit der tomatensauce
ich habe mich riesig couch gesetzt mit
häppchen und machen ja ach ja ich warte
bis die auberginen fertig sind aber wir
können auch die zwischenzeit nutzen und
somit ist es eigentlich auch ein sehr
sehr schnelles rezept in dem die
tomatensoße zu bereiten so ich habe hier
meinen beschichteten topf da gebe ich
ein bisschen olivenöl rein und dann
dürfte ich zwiebeln an ich habe jetzt
heute nur die roten da gehabt ganz
zufällig aber ihr könnt auch alles
übernehmen möchte twitter zeit sondern
gebe ich jetzt die rotenzimmern dazu der
mich fein gehackt und gibt dann auch
noch knoblauch dazu und dann leute nicht
wundern
zucker gibt auf jeden fall automatiken
sachen immer noch zucker dazu das
kompensiert nämlich richtig gut mit dem
geschmack
[Musik]
der zucker karamellisiert dann auch noch
mal in der pfanne daher auch noch einmal
super lecker unbedingt diesen schritt
beachten und als es gebe ich auch schon
passierte tomaten dazu ich habe jetzt
hier eine glasflasche mit 680 gramm wenn
jetzt eine 500 gramm flasche habt dann
füllt das gerne auf mit ein bisschen
wasser eigentlich ist das rezept sogar
fast vegan aber ich gebe da später noch
käse dazu weil ich einfach finde dass
sie geschmacklich super passt freut sie
vegan käse habt könnt ihr den natürlich
auch sehr gerne nehmen und jetzt fehlen
nur noch die gewürze dann nehme ich
natürlich salz und pfeffer und ich finde
das datum ja noch ganz gut mit dazu
passte
[Musik]
ihr müsst die so sind auch nicht köcheln
lassen also es ging jetzt eigentlich nur
darum dass man die die zwiebeln schönen
künste und den zucker karamellisiert und
ich probiere jetzt war und ich würde das
machen war lecker lecker lecker mehr
haben sie bringt mich der kamera oft zum
lachen macht geben als sie standhaft und
ziehe das voll durch
ähnlich denkt schon über ich habe jetzt
eine auflaufform und da werde ich jetzt
ganz einfach tomatensoße und die
fertigen auberginen schichten ihr seht
schon die sind ganz leicht gebräunt und
es gibt übrigens einen mythos bzw
nee kein mythos also damals ich kenne
das von meiner mutter so dass sie ob es
ihnen ganz viel salz gestreut hat damit
die ja nicht so bitter schmecken aber
heutzutage werden auberginen ganz anders
gezüchtet das heißt es braucht ihr gar
nicht mehr als ich mir jetzt vielleicht
schreibt dann müsse es aber vorher
erstmal salz drauf machen damit dass da
nicht so bitter schmeckt also die die
wird heutzutage bekommen die sind
einfach nicht mehr so wie damals vor 20
jahren fun fact fand ich auch super
interessant
[Musik]
ich bin erfolge käse fan deshalb mache
ich jetzt noch ein bisschen gouda käse
in die zwischenschichten das natürlich
optional das ist euch überlassen aber
ich weiß nicht finde das passt ja ich
sag ja wenn ihr wir gerne käse hab dann
könnte das natürlich super easy
abwandeln
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich abgeschlossen mit ein
bisschen gouda käse und ich hab noch
schafskäse dazu gegeben einfach für den
mediterranen touch und jetzt kommt das
in den backofen eigentlich nur noch so
lange bis der käse goldbraun ist bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze circa 15 bis 20
minuten schaut einfach von der käse
goldbraun ist und dann könnt ihr auch
schon essen dann ist nämlich das gericht
auch schon fertig raser und ich lassen
uns den auflauf jetzt schmecken und euch
ganz viel freude beim nachkochen
ich schreibe euch natürlich alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die
video beschreibung habt ihr fragen habt
ihr wünsche oder anregungen schreibt mir
und in die kommentare
da können wir doch gerne austauschen
ansonsten lasst es euch schmecken einen
guten appetit und ich würde mal sagen
bis zu meinem nächsten video teure kiki
[Musik]